this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
hey wisecrack michael here today we're
looking at the cartoon that dares to
combine deli meat with business casual
wear
[Music]
steven spielberg's animaniacs sure it's
a cartoon you may or may not remember
for its uh
hand puns no no no fingerprints
i don't think so wait does that mean
what i i think it means
animaniacs has one particular object of
derision that's worth digging into
hollywood and how it works or often
doesn't as it turns out
this kids show has a lot to teach us
about the dysfunction behind your
favorite cartoon shows and movies in
both the original series and the 2020
reboot so
how does a show with more mallets than a
hammer factory dissect the complicated
social and economic systems
behind our entertainment
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on animaniacs spoilers ahead for 90s
entertainment news and election results
and before we continue i want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor keeps
did you know that two out of three men
will experience male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35.
that statistic may be scary but luckily
prevention
is the key and no prevention doesn't
include avoiding hats or the sun
since it's all in your jeans enter keeps
keeps is an affordable hair loss
treatment plan that helps you keep the
hair on your
head keeps offers the generic versions
of the only two fda approved medications
for hair loss prevention
and they can ship this medication
straight to your door all you have to do
is visit a doctor
online and the medication will be sent
to you every three months
with keeps some men even experience hair
regrowth
find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors
and hundreds of thousands of men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication
for a limited time go to keeps.com
wisecrack
or click the link in the description to
get 50 percent off your first
order now back to the show first the
only real background you need
animaniacs is loosely framed around the
adventures of
brothers these three scamps yako echo
and dot periodically escape their prison
in the warner brothers water tower to
wreak havoc on the studio backlot and
well that's it
like i love lucy the dick van dyke show
30 rock and bojack horseman animatix
follows in a long hollywood tradition of
tv shows that are about making tv shows
fittingly the show gets a lot of its
laughs by pulling back the curtain on
hollywood
making fun of the gap between the
beautiful end products that viewers get
to enjoy
and the painstaking frustrating even
corrupt process that makes them happen
in other words nadx tries to make us
laugh by giving us exaggerated
cartoonified glimpses into how hollywood
really works can you read my screenplay
it's super original it's about a
screenwriter in los angeles
at its most basic level this approach
takes the form of jokes about the daily
grind of film production
in the original run sketch cutie and the
beast for example we sit with yako wacko
and dot
as they endure multiple exhausting
retakes of the opening scene of their
beauty and the beast parody
the warners quickly lose their patience
and start sniffing at each other
thanks for your support mr p-pop into
the mic
eventually dot publicly billed as the
cute or sweet one gets completely fed up
and
takes it out on everyone in earshot
that's my cute little sister who said
that even more navel gazy is the
animated x parody of orson welles
infamous frozen peas meltdown
in which the famous actor took
particular offense to the ad copy he was
reading
here's the animaniacs version that's
just idiotic if you'll forgive my saying
so that's just stupid
in july impossible meaningless
it of course changes the part where
orson welles says
get me a jewelry and show me how you can
say in july you know
go down on you get me a jury and show me
how you can say
in july and i'll make cheese for you in
segments like these animaniacs uses
humor to argue that the entertainment
industry is a lot less polished and a
lot more human
than it sometimes pretends to be
according to scholar john t
caldwell this is a crucial fact to bear
in mind when analyzing how the industry
behaves
in his article para industry researching
hollywood's blackwaters caldwell
cautions his fellow scholars not to
ignore the human elements while
analyzing how and why hollywood works
meltdowns and all the entertainment
industry he argues is
just as affected by societal issues as
the broader culture
it makes content for the entertainment
industry does what any other large group
does
form communities practice reputation
control and take part in certain
approved ritualistic behaviors some of
the most google-worthy jokes and
animaniacs revolve around hollywood's
socio-political communities
that is the friendships and petty
rivalries that form between actors
producers directors etc
and play a huge under-acknowledged role
in the way that movies and tv shows get
produced in the show's original run this
dynamic is shown in mockumentary
segments in which representatives of
old hollywood are interviewed about
their interactions with the warners
throughout the 20th century these
interviews reveal a community in which
the category of friend frenemy and
coworker are all mixed up with each
other see for instance
the long running feud between yakko
warner and comedian milton berle
barle and yakov were always going at it
yakko was always with the anvils on
burl's head we'd hear a noise feet look
and there was barrel with an anvil on
his head
this show also pokes fun at what
caldwell describes as the industry's
internalized imperative that everyone
must constantly market his
or her brand through a combination of
calculated workplace behavior and
effective online networking and
reputation management within the
animaniacs universe
a person's reputation is so important
that they are justified in doing
almost anything to protect it up to and
including
dropping a bomb on a critic's house in
this episode slappy and skippy squirrel
tortures siskel and ebert stand-ins
hisskel and egbert until they publicly
retract a negative review
now here's today's lesson skippy if you
want to go on national tv and shred
someone's career to pieces you have the
right
right but when you do that remember
don't go listing your home address in
the phone book while these jokes made at
hollywood's expense are mostly pretty
light-hearted the show can sometimes get
downright
cynical in its approach to the industry
this becomes particularly clear in its
commentary on the economics of
entertainment michael
the team talks with 20th fox means he
wants another 93 million
and how our favorite movies and tv shows
are inextricably tied up with the flow
of money and power
animaniacs talks about this a lot in a
show that's supposedly written for
kids there's a near constant discussion
of legal documents music licensing and
other industry topics children wouldn't
know the first thing about
contracts for instance are more than a
passing mention in the show's opening
theme song
in both the original series
and the 2020 reboot you should see our
new contract
the topic of contract negotiations also
plays a recurring role throughout both
iterations of the series wait a second
we got a contract our agent
with management and talent arguing
viciously about who should get paid how
much for what kind of work
the agent these kids got for themselves
was tough a real grinder
in one of the warner's early adventures
to the middle ages side characters
lament the fact that they can't sing
songs from camelot without paying for
the rights
[Music]
this preoccupation with money and
entertainment carries over into the 2020
reboot
the first episode of which ends with the
warner's accepting a giant
check moments after singing a song that
trashes hollywood's lack of originality
and constant recycling of old ideas
again and again the show implies that
money not artistic or cultural merit
is the main driver of what gets made in
hollywood and while this take on the
industry might feel a little jaded
especially for a kid show at least one
scholar would agree with it
in his book communication and capitalism
sociologist christian fuchs argues that
within the context of our capitalist
society
the purpose of the entertainment
industry is to produce attention that is
your attention which can then be
packaged up and sold to advertisers and
other buyers
who will pay good money to monopolize
your eyes and ears for 30 seconds at a
time from this bleak point of view
the entertainment industry looks less
like a collection of artists
trying to make beautiful moving films
and more like an assembly line of
factory workers laboring to transform
your time into marketable attention and
as in many factories working conditions
are
less than ideal fuegs contends that the
communication workers of the world are
united by the fact that they
all produce for and are exploited by
global communications corporations
put another way nearly everyone in the
entertainment industry is being squeezed
by the person above them to produce as
much as possible and return for payment
that doesn't nearly cover the value of
what they've made and sacrificed
this dynamic pops up again and again
throughout animaniacs with directors and
executives
leaning on creatives to constantly come
up with more and better work
get to places even if it destroys them
in the process
the 65th anniversary special for
instance imagines the warner's original
director as an angry boss who belittles
his employees and forces them to produce
above and beyond what could be
reasonably expected stay up all night if
you have to
i want funny the pressure gets so bad
that the creator loses his mind while
designing the characters
[Laughter]
and ultimately winds up in a mental
hospital later i found out he went all
funny in the head but i hear he's
getting better
we're having soup today in other words
according to the show's own logic
the warners and by implication many of
our favorite cartoon icons are a direct
result
of the industry's exploitation of an
animator a worker who in this case was
driven to insanity by over exertion
with regards to worker exploitation
little has changed between the series
original
run and the reboot the new fictionalized
warner brothers studio ceo is just as
willing to exploit her workers
as were her predecessors i don't care
that your girlfriend's new nose fell
into a subway toilet
we need that rewrite by the end of the
day the reboot also uses the animaniacs
formula to offer funny new critiques of
more recent industry developments in
particular
it has some interesting things to say
about the way that production and
advertising have evolved since the show
originally aired
in brief it satirizes the ways in which
content development is increasingly
driven
not by the decisions of individual
artists and executives but by a reliance
on data collected from prospective
audience members
animated x seems to be suggesting that
in a weird slightly creepy way
the perspective audience of a given
piece of film has become an unknowing
participant in the creative process
driving decisions about what gets made
and how
our friend fugues would agree and goes
so far as to argue that audience members
themselves have become
unpaid workers in an overarching
economic structure that includes the
entertainment industry
the advertising marketing industry and
social media platforms
as he puts it audience members are
audience workers creating attention as a
commodity while
users of ad financed internet platforms
are digital workers creating attention
data metadata and social relations as a
commodity
to put that in the simplest possible
terms without necessarily signing up for
it you become a worker in the worldwide
process of attention production
and you're on the job anytime you engage
with content watching it liking it
sharing it
talking about it and so on if you're
like much of the internet connected
world
you may spend hours in a given week
consuming and evaluating videos music
podcasts etc
in effect producing highly valuable
information and content for which you
never see a dime
but that's a video for another day the
animate ex reboot
calls out this new metrics obsessed
media landscape
directly in its theme song a brand new
cast who tested well in focus group
what's more in a funny musical number in
which the warners try to predict what
will happen between the reboots 2018
production and its 2020 release
the siblings acknowledge that their show
will succeed or fail based on how
quickly they can make themselves
relevant to whatever's being talked
about at the moment
[Music]
[Applause]
but the reboot's most direct response to
the quirky slash
terrifying implications of new media
comes in a pinky and the brain sketch
of mice and memes in it we learned that
way back in the 90s
the brain created the got dang internet
specifically for the purpose of
brainwashing and controlling the entire
planet here in 2020
he quickly gathers that the most
effective way to use this global
communications tool
is to gather as much attention from
internet users as possible
with their undivided attention they are
the perfect
unsuspecting pawns for my master plan
but of course like any self-aware
meta-happy show animated x eventually
has to offer some assessment of
its own role in the massive complicated
system that is the global entertainment
industry
we know we're selling out so it's cool
at least they're honest
what do you think wisecrack is the
animaniac's take on the entertainment
industry too pessimistic
not pessimistic enough let us know what
you think in the comments
huge thanks to our patrons for all your
support hit that subscribe button with
the force of a cartoon mallet
and be sure to subscribe and ring that
bell as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
you